it's when you have a group of people and
most of the people in the group believe
that most of the people in the group
believe something that in fact very few
of the people in the group believe but
since most of the people in the group
believe that everybody else in the group
believes this everyone acts as if
everybody believes it and you end up
following a norm that nobody likes
david mcgraney welcome to the show thank
you so much i am very honored to be
here in company that shares a lot of my
obsessions i feel there's a venn diagram
with a lot of overlap here right now and
that's always cool
when
you say that someone holds a belief
like the belief that our interests
heavily overlap in a venn diagram what
does that mean what what what is a
belief
this is the best opening question i've
received so far i want you today
uh
why would i i'll say the same thing back
to you that was said to me when i first
asked a researcher this someone who had
45 years of research into just beliefs
uh which they said
that is a tough one um that was jim
alcock who i asked uh i thought he'd be
the greatest person to go to at first
with these questions it's one of the
reasons why the book takes such a long
arc getting to a authoritative voice is
that i thought it would be a book where
i just went and asked experts experts
those questions
they tell me the answers i'd find the
relevant literature i'd translate it in
a fun approachable voice and boom you
have a book
uh that is not how it turned out because
it turned out i was asking questions
that have either
incredibly complex answers or no answers
yet
when it comes to that in particular
this thing i told you where i feel that
i we have a strong overlap
i could say
that there's a belief there there
certainly are some fact-based
information-encoded things in my brain
that have
emotional qualities of certainty
attached to them involved in that
proposition
but also i'm also expressing an attitude
i'm also expressing how i feel strongly
in one direction or another that i have
these positive and negative
evaluations of what i'm presenting to
you i'm also expressing a little bit of
things there about values i'm expressing
some
some notions of what is and isn't so in
every direction so
when it comes to just the raw fact based
thing
it's a huge assumption i'm making
based off of
information i've received so far in this
conversation and also from knowing a
little bit about you and sharing some of
our shared interests beforehand
and also we've developed a little bit of
trust and a little bit of rapport so
that i
have all these cues that are translating
into a
sub-emotional
state of certainty about all these
bullet points that
pile up into something we would call in
common parlance the belief that we have
an overlapping venn diagram of
obsessions that's the complicated answer
what's the breakdown that you went
through there it seems like there's
component parts that are making this up
yeah like i think the reason i like to
talk about it like this is
oh
though this book is about how minds
change and i was very adamant that that
would be the co the cover the title that
would be how minds change not how to
change people's minds i did not want to
write a book that was the modern version
of how to win friends and influence
people
i didn't want to do a retreat of the
ciaodini
influence type stuff i was actually
interested in how do minds change
whether or not that's through persuasion
whether or not that's through propaganda
whether or not that's through activism
and
despite that that tends to be what
people are or though this would be the
entry point that a lot of people are
coming to the book and i get that we're
at a very contentious polarized time and
that's something people want to think
about
and learn more about
but when you use the phrase how minds
change
that becomes a
just like
the previous answer becomes a very
nuanced and complicated uh
concept because some cultures don't
really
frame it that way
and when i think about the idea that
i've either changed my mind or i want to
change someone's mind or i have changed
someone's mind or anything in using that
phrase
i found that
when people were getting most frustrated
with other people when they were
attempting to change their mind in some
way that frustration often came from
assuming they were trying to change
their belief when really they were
trying to change an attitude
or there was an assumption in that
conversation that
we were taking our our fact-based
conclusions and having them do battle
with one another the way like maybe a
scientist would
there may be a uh
a prosecutor a defense lawyer would when
really what's often taking place is
are we having a battle of justifications
we're having a battle of
of reasoned justifications for why we
think felon believes something and if
you keep going backwards through the
processing chain
you'll find oftentimes that what's
motivating that
is
some sort of attitude or value set or
some sort of experience some sort of
thing that you can't help but feel and
that has led you to cherry-pick evidence
over time until you have some things
that seem like justifications and when
you approach another person that's
where the uh the contentious battle
takes place i'm going to throw these
links at you you're going to throw those
links at me i'm gonna say watch this
youtube video you're gonna say watch
this one but the reason those things
resonate for us are because something
within us
under you know it's in the book it's
we used a model called surf pad to
describe with us something within us led
us to those things and if that's not
part of the conversation
but it's probably going to take place as
nothing useful uh the debate will end up
being both parties feel more right than
wrong than they did before they started
and neither person moves any direction
at all they just become more entrenched
in whatever they had coming to the
conversation
what's an example of how somebody could
be let's say that we're having a
discussion about any topic you want
what's an example of how i could be
speaking from an attitude and you could
be speaking from a belief or from
whatever else
sure like uh i mean something that we
all experienced here recently was were
vaccines right um ed kovid
and i spent time with people who were
anti-vaxxers before uh it was coveted
anti-vaxxer stuff it was mmr stuff
and i spent time with researchers who
studied the impact of different
messaging all that
oftentimes what will happen is someone
you'll this is just sort of a broad
generalization here but you might
approach someone who is an anti-vaxxer
who and you say well why are you an
anti-vaxxer
and they'll say
because vaccines cause autism or
something that effect and then you'll
say well why is this and then they'll
start laying out where they heard it or
all the evidence they feel that supports
that proposition
and
they present it to you as if that's how
that's why they feel the way they feel
but probably but usually what's happened
is somewhere along the line
they've
been there are a million different
psychological processes that that lead
up to this consistency bias and the
introspection illusion and
all sorts of memory things that that
fall into place does the uh
belief change blindness is an actual
term
where it feels like yeah you were like
gandalf or something and you went to the
bottom of your
vast library and you read a bunch of
scrolls and you and you
wrote out this thesis and ah this is
what i believe about drag seeds
but
what probably is going on is that you
[Music]
you had a strong feeling it has strong
negative affect a strong negative
attitude
that then which could be in uh
influenced by experiences you've had but
it could also just be influenced by
elites in your or cultural norms or
social costs and rewards or just
raw fears that you may have about
authority and some sort of raw view you
have about
medical practices the idea of losing
agency the idea of all these things
being combined into something you don't
quite understand that's going to be in a
needle that's going to puncture the
flesh of your child against your will
these things led you to look for
justifications for that anxiety
justifications reasonable justifications
that you could argue in front of your
trusted peers and then you find this
thing you say ah that really justifies
what i think about this and then when
someone asks you why do you feel this
way that's what you present this is the
thing that led me to the feeling when
really it was the feeling that led you
to the thing
and we do that too when we think we're
being reasonable and when two people
disagree on something that's often where
the the sparks fly is that these uh we
have the process backwards and then we
argue backwards in a way that doesn't
really solve much of it
do you think
that
because the modern world has more
information than we've ever had before
and there are more things that can
justify our feelings is that one of the
reasons why we have such a multiplicity
of viewpoints and also people feeling
really ingrained in their beliefs and
and feeling super sort of fractured and
fragmented and unable to work out what
the truth is
a little i mean yes yes and no i mean
it's it's just different right than that
it used to be and how is it
i'm weirdly optimistic in that i think
that this is a phase that we'll get
through because we've had things that
have disrupted the information ecosystem
before
um the way it's different one of the big
things that makes it different is we can
form groups around anxieties much more
quickly than we ever could before and
then
uh tribal psychology group psychology in
group out group psychology will then
take
precedence it'll become the more
motivating factor than the thing that
led us into the group in the first place
that's something that is really
hyper present in the current information
ecosystem and the social media ecosystem
that we're in
and
the
the fact that we've this misinformation
has always been an issue or that uh
truth has very been that the truth has
been difficult to figure out has always
been part of the human experience but it
was tom stafford who uh told me and it's
a great quote i'll i'm not doing it
verbatim because i'm trying to remember
it but he said something to the effect
of
um
it's like germs before cities in his in
his mind like germs are always a problem
sanitation was always a problem but when
we had cities and we started living in
large groups and we were interacting in
a new way that's when that became a real
public health issue that had to be
addressed and not only did the cities
have to address it at the level of
cities but so did the citizens have to
address it at the level of washing your
hands and being good citizens who were
clean
well he said he feels that it's almost
it's very similar to what's happening
with misinformation that misinformation
has always been a problem in human
groups in one-to-one interactions
and
thanks to this new way of interacting
with each other that is at scale
where we have more contact with people
who see the world differently than us or
have we have more information outlets
than ever before lots of the information
gatekeepers have collapsed
then we will have to learn the
informational equivalent of washing our
hands and also the contexts the places
in which we meet will have to do a
better job of sanitation so i think in
that regard that's a big deal
the other side of that i know there's a
long-winded answer but there's another
element of all this which is
um
when we feel a strong anxiety uh like i
like i liking it i liken it to like if
you're in a tent
and
you hear a strange sound in the woods
you get this visceral negative feeling
and you're like what is that
you feel anxious you feel of negative
emotions
and because we're a social primate
one of the things you want to do is you
want to
go searching for
justification for that
feeling that
that your reaction to it is reasonable
that your heightened state of alarm is
reasonable
and reasonable means
literally coming up with reasons for why
you are responding in that way
so you might go out with a flashlight or
if it's a different
era you know a torch or if it's a
different area nothing at all and you
will try to find some sort of
something to some sort of evidence
that backs up your your reasoning
you do that in the modern information
environment and
anything that causes great anxiety for
some people people some people are very
prejudiced and they have anxieties about
things that
are seem heinous and strange some people
are just simply fearful or hesitant
about certain things that seems like of
course you would be
you go online looking for other for for
first of all you look for reasons why
the things that would justify that
feeling and you'll find it of course you
will but more so than that you will find
other people doing the same search and
you will join their search parties and
then now you have a community and the
communities are something that's pretty
new like there's always been like
conspiracy theories back and forth all
over the place but you know you had to
go to the library and for find somebody
in your hometown something
the idea that you can very quickly form
a jump into a group of a million people
having conversations about it where you
can
deeply radicalize each other as
something pretty new
what do you mean when you talk about a
post-truth world
i actually one of those people who i
don't like post-truth is a term i i
think uh i don't think we're in a
post-truth world any more than we've
ever been i think we're in a post-trust
world uh which in some ways ends up
being the same thing i guess
the
there's a great researcher uh named kate
starboard who talked to me about how
a lot of what we see in online behavior
is similar to what happens after uh a
crisis situation a natural disaster or a
ship sinking or a building burning
like we enter into a uh
we become aware that there are
information voids as she puts it and we
sort of
recalibrate
our epistemological approach to figuring
out what's going on to
being okay with rumors
and because because the information is
hard to come
the actual accurate information is kind
of hard to come by and you need to
respond quickly and you're really
motivated to lower your anxiety
so you um
you start modulating what you're what
you're going to do based off of trust
more than based on more than truth
so like you
someone tells you hey i heard you can
get water here or i heard that you
should go down these steps over this way
or i heard that what happened was this
and you you
if this person seems like if there's
somebody you've known for a long time
you'll know what kind of expertise they
have and you'll modulate your behavior
based off what trust you have and that
information
if it's somebody who's telling you they
heard it from somewhere else you'll very
quickly say like where did you hear that
because you want to know if you can
trust the source
and
whereas if it's like a firefighter or a
policeman or a soldier or something in a
situation like that you'd be much more
likely to just go with it
and
that's something that's similar now but
in the in that we have a lot of
anxieties a lot of we're on edge in a
lot of ways and the information
gatekeepers like i said before have have
sort of collapsed it's a very fragmented
information environment so we're
modulating a lot of what we
plan to do and also what we believe on
trust and
the banding trust back and forth has
become very valuable in that space so
it's not so much post trust is supposed
truth is is uh post trust is very we're
all trying to figure out who can we
trust and we're all very
eager and sensitive to when people
violate the trust that we put in them
and we're very quick to say okay well
i'm not trusting you anymore i'm not
taking more information from that source
so
that's my current that's my current
thinking on things that's that's one of
the things i proselytize and talk about
the book i like that framing i think
that in
what what i see online is a lot of
people
who are their grift radar or their their
shill alarm is hyper attuned you know as
soon as they see that somebody might
have perverse incentives or that they
think that they're doing something for
the wrong reasons they're very very
quick to get rid of them and once you
sell your integrity on the internet it's
very difficult to buy it back at least
with
people that have good memories now
that's not to say that you can't capture
an audience and then continue to push a
narrative to them which is untrue
um
but
does more information help then because
we have access to more information than
ever before surely people's minds should
be more accurate than they've ever been
yeah you would think uh that was the
dream for for of many generations uh i
talked about that in the book the um
the 19th century rationalist
philosophers the founding fathers of the
united states uh
the cyberpunk uh champions of the 1990s
and beyond they all
had this sort of similar dream the like
the the founders they were they were
like if we have public libraries
then everybody will be able to have have
the same amount of information that you
had used to have to be
a fancy pants elite person who went to a
school
but now everyone has it those are you
had to be rich and have a library at
home
and so their dream was like everybody
has a library in their hometown now
everybody will have access to all the
same information and democracy will
finally flourish and blossom
the
19th century philosophers they were very
into the idea of public education if we
just make it so that you everybody gets
some basic schooling then everybody will
have access to all the facts and the
facts will will everybody will agree on
what those facts mean and
enlightenment for all
the cyberpunks they were like okay when
we get the internet we will no longer
have
these three p three news stations that
tell you what's going on people will go
we'll have all the information available
all the
the world's the library of alexandria of
a new age will be upon us and it will
all have all the same facts we'll all
agree on what those facts mean and then
we will enter into a cyber enlightenment
and we'll go to the moons of jupiter
together
so the idea that this is this is
something that is called the information
deficit hypothesis
it's the idea that the reason people are
wrong is because they don't have the
facts yet you give them all the facts
and then they'll change their minds and
be right
but
the problem here is that we're motivated
reasoners and
we
don't just accept evidence
because it's evidence we accept evidence
based off of all the motivations we
bring to the table when we come looking
to
justify something or create
consider what's rational we worry about
the social groups we're part of we worry
about our standing within the social
groups we are
approaching it from all the experiences
we've had so far and all the ignorances
we have inside of us so we will either
assimilate or accommodate based off all
those things
and the facts by themselves
well the facts just don't speak for
themselves that's all that comes down to
it somebody always speaks for them and
the same evidence in front of two
different sets of eyeballs may be
interpreted completely differently we
know this just from what like there are
a
thousand studies where they show people
a video of something
and uh
the video like the uh well small
favorite research they show people
protesting but the protesters you can't
tell what the protesters are protesting
exactly it just looks like some people
protesting and they will prime the
groups they'll they'll get people who
are strongly left or strongly right on
the political spectrum and then they'll
subdivide that to say to some of them
they'll say these people are protesting
against something you are a big believer
in or you'll say they're protesting
protesting for it and you can imagine
what happens there depending on how you
tell people what the people are doing in
the video they see the video as as
evidence of something completely
different compared to the other person
you prime a person to think that these
are people protesting against something
you believe in
and
you will have all these negative
emotions and you'll
you'll find that what's going on in the
video is heinous and terrible and then
all that and you'll see things the other
people don't see it all goes back to
that old research of uh they saw a game
where they had people uh
watch a football game
and
uh they had to count how many times the
whole the home team or the away team uh
did naughty things and depending on
which one you're
a member of the the
support for one team or the other you
saw a different game and that was that
was the title of the paper they saw a
game but they did they the same video
different game even though it's right
there and we saw this all throughout
politics and especially in the uh
all the
trials and things that took place during
the trump era all the uh the the
hearings like you would you would there
was all this i remember on social media
there was all this uh
excitement on the left for like finally
like this this will finally this video
will come out we will all watch it and
and they'll all see the truth
but of course like it comes out we all
watch the same video and everybody sees
something else in it some people see it
as oh see i told you trump's great and
other people watch it go oh see i told
you trump's terrible same video same
evidence different interpretations and
i get it for i understand that for a
long time it felt like all we needed was
more facts but
that's why facts are not the way to get
into these things if you have no concern
no cognitive empathy for the fact that
people will interpret things through a
lens of their priors through a lens of
their motivations and tribes i heard
someone reverse shapiro's
famous quote the other day that says
facts don't care about your feelings
it's that feelings don't care about the
facts it's like look i've got i've got
my position and [ __ ] you i don't care i
don't care about what you want to do so
who was the guy that said um people
aren't flawed
and irrational they're biased and lazy
oh man that's hugo mercier
er
i keep promoting my own book but at the
same time i'm asking people if you've
never read the enigma of reason this is
a book you should if you're like a super
nerd about all this like i am like you
are like you got to get the enigma of
reason in your brain uh he's also
written another book since then called
uh uh not born yesterday about uh trust
and elites and things like that uh about
uh mob behavior and and the things that
he basically makes a case against it but
the
it was one of the first things that i
that that well honestly in how minds
change there's a comeuppance i mean the
book is also a a story about how i had
to change my own mind about some things
that i was
suggesting that i was putting out there
in the world that i no longer feel that
way about um and
there's a there's two comeuppances i i i
there's a peanut butter and chocolate
have come up it's in the book um one is
uh tom stafford's work into the truth
wins scenario and the other is hugo
mercier and dan sperber's working into
the interactionist model
and
the simplest way to
to
put that out there is
their work
puts forth evidence and they have
studies and they have a whole giant
structure it's a great big beefy model
at this point
that
human
cognition uh when it comes to
group-based reasoning and the you know
we we put our minds together toward
common goals we try to figure out a
world view that we can all agree upon
it's a great powerful tool that ultra
social primates with the gift of
language can employ in all sorts of
situations
that the selective pressures
put on us as we were trying to get
better as we were working to get better
and better at that
led to
biological structures that lead to
cognitive mechanisms that have two broad
functions one is to produce arguments
and the other is to evaluate them
and when we produce arguments we produce
them in a very biased and lazy way
which is not the same as flawed and
irrational which is i was part of that
whole pop psychology
wave
10 12 years ago of books about that
we're all like hey do you can you
believe how flawed we are you can be how
silly we are
uh can you believe we lock our keys in
the car and we send emails to people we
shouldn't have and then we also cause
climate change so that was like the the
big push of like be careful we're very
irrational creatures but as they put it
like it it's actually quite rational and
it's working exactly as it evolved to
work
to
when you are faced with the possibility
of disagreement or you're trying to
deliberate and come to consensus
that each individual would put forth a
very biased
argument which means it's very strongly
from their perspective very strongly
from their experiences and their
concerns
and it would be very lazy and that it's
going to be the easiest thing to put
forth the thing they can justify the
easiest in the moment
that takes very little cognitive labor
and then you dump that into an
argument pool and then the other
mechanisms work inside that pool where
you everybody evaluates things very
carefully
and
in that situation you offload all the
cognitive labor to the group based
process
the
they have great studies where they're
mentioned in the book like where you
have people uh
they will have them produce arguments
and then they will trick them into
thinking the arguments are someone
else's arguments and if they think it's
their argument
they will almost 100 percent of the time
say yeah this is great i'll see anything
wrong with this if they're tricked into
thinking somebody else
produced that argument somewhere in the
seventy percent range they'll find all
the all of the flaws and analogical
things in it and the fallacies and
everything and say see what are you
thinking here
what matter why that matters in a modern
discourse is that many of the platforms
in which we engage with one another in
these ways
they're just built to incentivize
argument production but not really
argument evaluation
the they're
the in the it's the same reason that i
was wrong about this for so long most of
the studies that i
uh wrote about in blog posts and and
were in books just like everybody else
writing at the time this the literature
we were pulling from
those studies were done on large groups
of people but each person was being
studied in isolation like you'd give
them a problem from the cognitive
reflection task or you would present
them with something like the wayson you
know task or some one of these things
that are very popular in psychology
and you would
demonstrate that as alone an individual
reasoner would very often the majority
of the time get these things incorrect
but as uh that's the other side of the
peanut butter and chocolate of my
comeuppance is that tom stafford has
demonstrated which is this plays with
hugo mercier's research that
if you take those exact same studies and
you give them to groups then the group
what usually will happen like if you if
you study a large group of people and
most of them get the thing wrong or they
they commit some sort of cognitive bias
reasoning thing
that small there is a percentage of them
that don't do that
and in isolation that doesn't really
help anybody but if you
have a group of people and i've done
this i've done lectures without you i
use this it's really fun i'll take uh
like the widget problem
uh or just what's
uh if it takes five machines five
minutes to make uh five widgets how long
will it take 100 machines to make 100
widgets
uh and
if you ask that people individually
about 70 of people will get it incorrect
if you
because you start trying to do math when
it's been really it's just the same
thing repeated so it's just five minutes
that there's all is this but
what i'll do is i'll ask a group of
people
this question
and i'll say
alone come up with an answer
and sometimes i'll put them into smaller
groups but it works even better when you
do the entire audience
and then i'll
ask is there anyone here who feels like
they have the right answer and i mean
they really feel it
and when that person raises their hand
they'll bring a microphone out to them
and say tell me what the answer is
they'll say five minutes and then you'll
hear the whole audience go
and then i'll say uh
please explain your reasoning and then
they'll explain it in detail
and then the whole audience goes ah
and then i can say to them yes research
the latest research shows that
what just happened here was most of us
were wrong
and because we were able to reason as a
group in a in a way that was a we
created this good faith
trusting rapport
strong rapport environment
now we're all right we went from almost
all wrong to almost all right
and this is just something that has been
difficult to
reproduce in online contexts and there's
there are many organizations working on
it but the current version of like
twitter and facebook and and all the
others
it's just
more it's very similar to the oscillated
thing where
it's a bunch of individual people who
feel like we're talking to each other
but we're really just kind of
taking our bias and lazy arguments and
throwing them in a big pile and seeing
what happens next and the evaluation is
rarely about the
logic or the reasoning process it's more
about like
are you saying that you're in this group
or that group right now i'm trying to
figure out if if we're it that's where
it's all it's not that we couldn't do it
otherwise it's just that's what's
incentivized right now that's what
creates engagement and that's what sells
advertisements and that's sort of where
it's at it can change and i think that
hopefully we will change it but that's
where i'm at with it well think about
what a lot of tribal beliefs actually
are they're shows of fealty to your own
side it's proof to your compatriots that
you value the group consensus over
rationality or truth itself saying look
there may be some counter evidence
against this particular thing but i am
such a loyal
uh disciple of this that i'm going to do
it and it's a threat display to your
enemies as well it's saying look this is
me my beliefs and i are one and to your
own side any deviation from that looks
like a lack of commitment and to the
other side it looks like weakness and um
a lack of understanding of your own
argument so it doesn't surprise me that
people become
entrenched in things like this
speaking of which you did some research
about the westboro baptist church didn't
you um i
in the book i went to several organs
there's even there's a chapter that we
took out where i went even went into
several conspiracy conspiracy theory
communities and and cults and
pseudo-cults it used to be a strong
portion of the book but that i was like
i'm i'm i'm gonna have to write three
books to put all this into one thing so
i we pared it down to i spend time with
9 11 conspiracy communities and i spend
time with westboro baptist church
who are the westbrook baptist church for
the people that don't know
so um westwood baptist church is
considered the um probably the
the most reviled hate group in america
they
are a baptist church like any other
baptist church there's there's thousands
of them all across the united states but
this one in particular
uh
decades ago
began at first they were protesting uh
they had they claimed that there were
men who were hooking up in their um
in the park in outs in kansas in kansas
city in topeka kansas i mean uh and they
protested it they they sent stuff on fax
machines to like senators and things and
they just got some media attention from
that
and that led to them seeking media
attention and becoming really good at it
and
that escalated to the point where they
started protesting everything they could
find they eventually protested the
funerals of soldiers coming back from
war
and with signs that would say thank god
for dead soldiers because they were
saying
america is is corrupt and polluted and
it all goes back to lgbtq issues which
they're very opposed to the very idea
that someone would find someone of the
same sex attractive or pursue a romantic
relationship with them and they
they became
incredibly vocal uh
protesters of that and
they're
really really mean about it
um they entered america most of
americans
discovered them when they protested the
funeral matthew shepard who was brutally
beaten
and
killed
just for simply being a gay a young gay
man
and they just protested his funeral and
they were saying like yay i'm glad he's
in hell and that
as
clearly that made a lot of people go oh
wow you are some awful human beings
but
they're so adamant in their protesting
and they started going online and doing
protesting like one-on-one with on
twitter and facebook and stuff um
it became uh
it was
a few of the people in the organization
started to leave and one of them in
particular megan phelps roper she left
after someone on twitter
extended their hand to her and carefully
empathetically compassionately
guided her out of the organization and
i wanted to talk to her and to
scientists who study what happened there
because i
i just feel i felt like
i can unders like i i've been frustrated
with family members who want to change
their minds about all sorts of things
the idea that somebody could leave an
organization like that after spending
most of their life defending what they
feel and believe
i wanted to know what it took
and if that was something that there
were insights there for
for applying it to all sorts of things
that we are frustrated with
and what i discovered there was
something that was the same thing i
found in every other every other person
who had left a community
of that nature whether it was
conspiratorial cult religious or
whatever
i had this misconception that there must
have been
something that that caused them to leave
and then
uh they had changed their mind about the
group and then they left but most often
what happened was they left the group
and then they changed their mind
the influence of the group was less
potent on them and it changed the
goggles they were wearing were replaced
by different ones
but the way out of that
almost always was
some someone
first of all didn't approach them with
hate and vitriol and i totally would
understand of course you'd want to
confront somebody that way
they instead confronted them with
compassionate empathetic non-judgmental
listening
they would ask them questions they would
not react poorly they would joke around
with them they would
encourage them to deeply introspect as
to why they feel the way they feel and
then allow that person
that who they're treating that way to
discover the inconsistencies on their
own
and more more than anything discovered
there were values they held
that they could satisfy and affirm
outside of the group that they had grown
up within or the one they had fallen
into
and
once the person got on that path it
becomes an off-ramp to get out of
something that was making them
uncomfortable
there usually was an inciting moment
with uh with megan it was
many of the people that left westboro it
was they had made these changes within
the organization where they were
being
oppressed in a way they hadn't been
before like they had made changes where
women couldn't have certain rights and
women couldn't behave in a certain way
um had to wear certain clothes
the they had to take on certain jobs
they had to go to school for certain
things those things were sort of the
crack
that led in the light and then but there
still had to be light but there had
still had to be someone who was willing
to be
empathetic and compassionate and listen
to them that gave them an opportunity to
entertain a possibility that maybe my
values could be better served outside of
this group and once
once you get a taste of that and you
actually do attempt to get outside the
group for a second and you get
validation for it there's a real strong
off-ramp to get out of those groups
didn't you look at the jim jones
massacre as well
i did that for the podcast man i really
wish i could have put out the book i i
i that deserves its own book and maybe
one day i'll do something like that
pluralistic ignorance my favorite term
in all of psychology that's what the jim
jones thing was about
so pluralistic ignorance and uh first of
all hard thing to say hard words to say
and uh
and even more difficult in the podcast i
let like 20 people give me their
definition of this thing because it's
every definition is different but it's
all the same ideas just a hard thing to
put into words without having to like
come up with a million metaphors
what it comes down to is it's when the
majority of it's when you have a group
of people
and
most of the people in the group
believe that most of the people in the
group believe something that in fact
very few of the people in the group
believe
but since everyone most of the people in
the group believe that mostly everybody
else in the group believes this everyone
acts as if everybody believes it and you
end up following a norm that nobody
likes
and
this is very common we are all you and i
are both doing it for something right
now everyone is experiencing this at all
times in some way
and it comes down to we hold we don't
always explicitly state how we feel
about things and so we have to make an
assumption based off of the cues that
people present
and the cues that people present may
indicate well they must believe it if
everybody's doing it they must actually
want to be doing it right so
the the foundational research in this
was about uh drinking norms on campuses
most freshmen can't do not like go
starting a new college career and then
immediately having to get blackout drunk
every weekend
most people do not want to do that
but most people do that and most people
do that for a couple years
so why is everybody doing something that
nobody wants to do because everybody
thinks that everybody else wants to do
it except them everybody thinks that the
only person that doesn't want to do it
and
this is rife all throughout politics
it's right through everything it's a
very fundamental thing that human beings
do and in
the on the podcast and
when you are not so smart i um
i did a show about this and i wanted to
show
there was fresh research into this about
there's an assumption that the emperor's
new clothes scenario is how you bust
this up but there was there's really
good research
from rob willer
and it shows uh it doesn't really do
like you can't count on the emperor's
new clothes sometimes it works but in
the jim jones example
there was one woman who stood up usually
what often what happens is it takes one
person like a stand-up comedian or
something just say out loud hey are we
all really doing this and then that that
creates change
the
right catalyzes change
in the
jim jones it was the hardest episode
i've ever done because i had to listen
to that tape
that you can i got it through uh i got
it through legitimate sources but you
can just find it online if you want to
get it
uh i have links to it on my website too
if anybody wants to hear it it's hard to
listen to one of the reasons it's hard
to listen to is because the uh
they cut they they copied over their
tapes all the time so there's this
haunting um
like hymnal spiritual music taking place
underneath everything as if it's a music
bed but it's just because they they
taped over it so often
and it's hard to listen to because you
[Music]
you hear everyone arguing about whether
or not they're going to commit mass
suicide and then slowly over time
everyone gets quieter and quieter until
they're it's silent because they are all
dead and it's not just adults it was
like
uh like 700 people and 300 children it
was awful right
um and they did it by taking cyanide
inside of uh
flavoraid um not kool-aid as we often
say
the the reason is that right
that's right it's flavor it was flavored
yeah uh flu i guess flavor aid will
forever be thankful that we that
kool-aid is a more popular drink because
of that but that's what that's what they
did drinking the flavor right yeah
drinking the flavor abe um
what the reason i did a show about it
was the one woman stood up
and said hey let's not do this there's
only one
jim jones and there's a thousand of us
why would we kill ourselves and our
children i think this is crazy let's not
do it
and she was shouted down by the rest of
the group and
she
also died and they all and
the in the episode we go into detail
about why
you would be willing to die
for a norm you don't believe in for and
it clearly demonstrates that
our
belonging goals trump all other goals in
certain situations so we are we are
social primates and that can be
whether or not it's intentional
it can
there's a confluence of psychological uh
phenomena that can they can become a
perfect storm of uh mega influence upon
us that can lead us to do things like
mass suicides
i mean doesn't that show perfectly that
social pain
or social death is literally scarier
than physical death to people it really
is that's uh i'm so glad you said that
uh
brooke harrington gave told me that and
i can't forget it she said if there was
an equals mc square of social science
would be uh the fear of social death is
greater than the fear of physical death
and
uh
we are we are willing to sacrifice
ourselves or kill
uh if we're willing to put ourselves in
physical harm
put ourselves at risk of physical harm
if it means that our reputation will
survive beyond us
and
we see that in it
even when stakes are low we see that
when people arguing anything from gun
control to climate change to fracking
people will do that
but even when the stakes are really high
of course we see it we see with the jim
jones massacre
we see it in all sorts of situations the
we say the war i mean that's where it
comes out the most right
the
i asked her about that and i said it my
metaphor just to see if i could make
sense of it was i was imagining like if
the ship is sinking like who am i gonna
put on the lifeboat i was like i'll put
my social self in the lifeboat and then
i'll go down with the ship
and she's like yeah that's that's what
we usually pick if we're given that
proposition
well you can see how
i guess in some situations this could
cause people tribally to do something
noble you know you might um save
the tribe by stopping some predator that
was coming toward it because even though
you know that you're going to suffer
physical pain or potentially death you
know you're going to do it and
apart from the drive that you might have
family and you've got sort of this
reciprocal altruism thing going on but
on top of that you know that socially
it's going to do you pretty well people
are going to be happy with you when
you're at your funeral yeah the
everything i've ever written about uh
i'm taking a note because i was really
well put uh
uh
the everything i ever
have written about
these things that we point out is like i
can't believe people do this we're
pointing out when these things go wrong
and they lead to bad outcomes but over a
long time scales over the entire
evolutionary history of our species
these must have led to
either they were neutral or they led to
positive outcomes because they they are
adaptive in some way precisely you had
to you had to not be in a deficit with
these things or else they would have
been competed out of the gene pool the
people that did
the actions that weren't effective at
survival or reproduction are long gone
and maybe maybe some of those i often
think about this i often think
what traits
have
arisen and then been competed out
that in 2022 would be amazing for people
to have
yeah you know like like
i've never heard that framing that's
really interesting i like that well
think about you know like differences in
risk aversion or differences in
tribalism or different thresholds for
making decisions or
changing your mind or holding on to
whatever all of that stuff um
there's been
tons tons millions of different quirks
and changes in our psychological makeup
and our physical makeup as well you know
there'll have been somebody born at some
point in history who probably had
14 fingers and you go well i mean what
you know what if 14 feet you'd be able
to type really fast on a keyboard that'd
be pretty useful but
all of these things weren't useful at
the time but i i often think about uh
what would have happened if one
particular strand had managed to sustain
and then it would have become adaptive
in the modern era
yeah i like uh that's great i like that
i'm going to steal that and i will
attribute it to you as much every time i
do so uh
yeah the
the thing that had that what happened in
the jim jones massacre was the result of
things that were adaptive over a long
evolutionary history being put into a
unfamiliar alien context all at once and
created an unlikely outcome
and that happens so rarely that we can
absorb that kind of outcome as a species
you every time we introduce these new
contexts for us to behave we get
something
novel as a as an outcome but the
behavior that's taking place is ancient
every time
the
clay shirky i remember once wrote that
uh technology doesn't create behavior it
uh lowers the cost to exhibit behavior
that was already there usually is what
takes place right so
you see the way people we the way we act
on social media even though it's become
it's almost become old man yells at
cloud at this point because i mean how
long are we going to have social media
before we how long does social media
have to exist before we consider that
new thing that's weirdness out it's
almost like arguing about television at
this point
but it is a we still haven't sorted out
how to do it well
and that's and and eventually we had
like a president on twitter doing weird
stuff that made us really go maybe maybe
politicians shouldn't have twitter like
we're still in that place because we
there's nothing that donald trump was
doing on twitter that the politician
hasn't done for a thousand years it's
just they were doing it in this new
context and we were and there's nothing
we were doing in response to it that we
haven't done for a thousand years it's
just we were doing a new context that
made lowered the cost to do so many
things that we got a different outcomes
from it
even in the how minds change
stuff there's a
people often ask like why why do people
resist changing their mind because if
you were to update when you shouldn't
you might either become wrong like uh or
you might if you or if you did um if you
didn't update when you should you might
stay wrong there's a real precarious
tightrope there
and in a different
um
with different uh
like in a different context that could
lead you to being eaten or not getting
enough food to survive if you update it
when you shouldn't and so
we're careful about like the if your
neighbor says hey i think you should eat
these berries it's not much different
than you know your cousin telling you
maybe you should drink this bleach and
i don't know if i should change my mind
about bleach but then again wait with
covid maybe i should be careful i know
you start to modulate it so we roll we
walk that tightrope with everything and
that's very adaptive
is there a
um
how would you say a set point or a
current view
bias that people hold i was at this uh
heterodox academy conference this
weekend one of the guys said a quote i
absolutely loved that said there are
many ways to change the world few will
make it better many will make it worse
and the point is that the behavior and
the beliefs that you've had have led you
up to this point and no matter how
miserable and melancholic your existence
has been you're still alive so you have
some degree of proof that the current
way that you're behaving and programming
is causing you to move forward in the
world is effective right i'm not dead
because if i was dead i couldn't be
thinking about whether or not to make
this decision
so
it does that cause people
to have um like a safety
net a degree of risk aversion for just
thinking anything new simply because i
know that what i do now has been
effective so far
yeah definitely like the short answer is
yes and
the long answer
mining how much time we have i will is
that
uh there's a point called the effective
tipping point but the it's it that is
and
to make sense of that we have to quickly
talk about assimilation and
accommodation
piaget put this forth this is this is
these are this is if you ever if you
want if you wanted to answer how do
minds change this is a pretty
straightforward answer through
assimilation and accommodation
assimilation is when you encounter
something uncertain or novel or
ambiguous
you
disambiguate it you arrive at some level
of certainty and you make it
uh make sense of it
by assimilating it into your current
model
and the way
i describe in the book is if a child
sees a dog for the first time uh and you
say it's like what's that you say it's a
dog something categorical happens in the
mines like four legs furry non-human
wagging tail
dog
then they see a horse
and they've never seen one before and
they just point at it and go dog that's
assimilation because categorically it
seems like it fits into my model
four legs non-human furry tail
but if you say to the child no that's a
horse now something has to happen which
is
there's a lot of cognitive load in this
there's it's a difficult process you
have to create levels of abstraction
there's neural networks have to do stuff
you have to literally
expand your mind because you have to
create a category in which both horse
and dog can fit which means you have to
create a new perceptual category which
expands the range of your understanding
of the world that's called accommodation
so now animals can be named two
different things that's a crazy and
we're doing this at all times both
things are happening at all times some
of our conversation makes sense to us
because we're assimilating constantly
into what we already understand about
things but at certain points i if i
especially if i feel challenged or i
feel some dissonance i'm going to need
to accommodate to make sense of what's
going on
we typically resist the accommodation
because there's more risk in that just
as
exactly as you described assimilation is
way less risky even if it leads me to be
factually incorrect it doesn't lead me
to being
dead so like i can be wrong about stuff
it's better to think that rustling in
the bushes
is a tiger than to go looking to see if
it's uh maybe it's a rabbit i don't know
it's better to stay safe and err on the
side of being wrong about that
the
but there's a point at which we can't do
that there's a breaking point called the
effective tipping point in the book it's
it's a
long answer to what it is but it comes
down to
there is a level beyond which
uh counterfactual or counterattitudinal
uh information will will cause you to
feel so strongly that you need to update
that you will commit to an update
um and they call it the effective
tipping point it's it's a lot it can be
above 30 it's
for raw neutral politically neutral
information it's around 30 percent of
the evidence coming in has to be is to
counter the evidence that you've already
seen
but if you add social costs if you had
motivations if it's like my job depends
on it or something that number can go
way higher than that but there is a
place it's just the number can go up
depending on how many motivations you
have to not change your mind about
something
so that's why people's minds change that
there is a
degree of
information coming in
that is so overwhelming that they they
basically can no longer be
unconvinced
of that position but the problem is that
when you layer on top of it
tribal bias
all of the other um
reasons that people have to not change
their mind
that that threshold can continue to go
up and up and up and up and up i
remember god sad was talking about he
does marketing and consumer stuff i
think at
uh wherever he is concordia or something
um
and he was talking about he wanted to
know what caused people to decide when
they were going to buy something
and i think that it was something i
think it was a similar sort of tipping
point that people reached so it's like a
threshold right yeah it's a in the it's
risk reversal it's risk versus reward
like you were saying but it's like this
meaty giant algorithm of every risk
every reward combined because
if i if i change my mind about this
what's my what are my friends and family
going to say that's part of it like
how's this going to affect my finances
that's part of it well i have to update
everything i've ever thought about this
thing like one simple example is uh like
if i if you have a friend who's really
in the quentin tarantino movies and they
tell you hey quentin tarantino has a new
movie coming out and you'd be like cool
and then like they might be wrong about
it but you just like say what's the risk
what's the harm
i believe you uh
however if that same friend tells you do
you know that quentin tarantino uh isn't
actually a real person it's been danny
devito this entire time wearing a hyper
advanced mech suit
uh
you're going to be like
so like there's a higher threshold for
believing that even though you trust
your friend and think they love quentin
tarantino but it's somewhere in that
media algorithm you've determined
there's more risk than reward in
accepting that information at face value
and
you change that to a political concept
or something that's deeply connected to
your identity and you can imagine that
you might have a similarly high
threshold for accepting that information
into your model of reality
what did you learn about arguing
arguing
arguing you know
it's
it's good
i like that we're arguing out so much on
the internet arguing is how we change
minds and
we are set up we're biologically set up
to receive and deliver arguments in a
way that gets gets us
ahead in the world that changes things
that progresses the human condition that
evolves our ideas that layers on new
abstractions for us to make sense of
things that articulates the ineffable my
friend this is all good for us
it's just that um the way in which we're
arguing
isn't the way we're arguing in con in
the same sort of context in which we
evolved to do so
and i think that we'll the frustration
we have when it comes to people who who
don't seem to see things our way
it's like the frustration you would get
if you're trying to reach the moon with
a ladder is what i say in the book
like and then you get you're like you
say well the moon's unreachable so
what's the point in our so you you
change that to people and you say look
those people are unreachable there's no
point in arguing with them the
frustration shouldn't be in them the
frustration should be in the way in
which you're trying to approach them
and
if you
are attempting to argue in a way where
you're trying to show that i'm right and
you're wrong and you can assume that
they're going to be doing the same thing
the the debate is going to end in in
nothing useful for either party but come
on i mean you know people people have
conversations where they they try the
most gentle subtle most well thought out
softly introduction and and the person
on the other side of the fence just
impressively seems to be able to
disregard with vitriol everything that
they're saying sure but that's your
frustrating that's your fault that's the
person who's arguing with them's fault
because we are all open to changing our
mind if it's presented to us if the
conversation's presented to us in a way
in which we feel like we
can trust the other person the other
person that has empathy for us they are
compassionate they are transparent
they're not trying to affect our agency
they're not going to shame us we're not
going to be ostracized that i might get
something out of it
does that not suggest that
not engaging
is the best form a lot of the time let's
say that
um
there are a large proportion of people
on twitter whom
for certain subjects they will not
change their mind it is simply the
medium that they are unprepared to
change their mind over given this topic
or that topic or the other one like the
threshold that you need to breach with
them the bandwidth that twitter allows
you to get across simply isn't going to
allow that to happen
you were absolutely correct i love that
you said that this is you're the first
person to ever put it that way and i uh
in a conversation anybody i've talked to
about this and it's really well put and
really it's a it's a great point
yeah we can't do this unless we're in a
good faith environment and sometimes we
don't have a choice when it comes to
creating that good faith environment
there are some environments that are by
default bad places to have that kind of
conversation
and acknowledging that upfront is great
and you could take that same person that
you
beforehand would be a bad idea to engage
with them and say maybe we should take
this somewhere else or we should move
this to a different context and i'm not
saying move it to one of those stupid
debates that people have on stage
between like an atheist and a
creationist that helps no one everybody
walks into that thinking the same thing
that they do when they walk out don't do
that
you need to sit that needs to be
in a place where there's not an audience
where the people are not concerned about
what's going to happen when when their
friends and family or their peers see
what they have to say about it which is
also what happens on facebook people on
facebook are arguing feeling like
they're they're on stage and there's a
whole audience gonna go boo whenever
they say the wrong thing
one-on-one in some way or another
whether it's email old-fashioned
missives or at a bar or a pub or over
dinner that's where you actually could
connect with someone using these old
things
until we create online environments that
replicate that you're right the the
it may be a bad idea to engage people in
places that by default create a bad
faith interaction between you and the
other person from all of the research
that you did what is your favorite
strategy
to
help people
positively uh change others minds
i
i found it blew it blew me away like
motivational interviewing is is probably
the most powerful thing there is but it
comes out of the therapeutic models but
it was very um
it blew my mind to find that there were
all these organizations around the world
who had stumbled into the same insights
as that therapeutic model because they
were just doing a b testing at people's
front steps or they were doing it on
college campuses
in the book i talk about deep canvassing
and
street epistemology but also
motivational interviewing cognitive
behavioral therapy smart politics all of
them use pretty much the same technique
in pretty much the same order which is
pretty much the socratic method but with
a lot of added psychological insights
put into it
you open up by establishing rapport and
trust and assuring the other person
that
we're going to just talk to each other
and explore each other's reasoning in a
way that helps both of us maybe figure
out why we're what we why why would we
disagree about this where does it come
from and then you ask for specific
claims you ask for sort of a measurement
of confidence in that claim you ask for
reasons why you hold that confidence and
then you ask well how did you arrive at
this the belief that or well how did you
how did you arrive at the conclusion
that that was a good reason to hold this
in such high confidence
and then you just let the conversation
spool out from there and often all the
work will be done on the other side and
they will come to a new way of of seeing
seeing it and seeing something in a new
way differently than you did before the
conversation is
changing your mind
that same conference that same lecture
that i was at this weekend he explained
about how
a lot of the students that he has are on
the far left and he puts this quote up
on the board using the socratic method
to get them to
be aware that always pushing for uh
social justice is not necessarily the
best way to do things and it's this big
quote and it says the
inner health
of the individual can never be um
justified until the external social
social justice health of the society has
been something else how many people
agree with this and it's like the sort
of thing that everybody would agree with
then he presses one button and it comes
up below that adolf hitler 1920.
so funny look david mccraney ladies and
gentlemen i really appreciate your time
if people want to keep up to date with
what you're doing and get the book where
should they go
uh you can find me at davidmcgraney.com
or you are not so smart of course my
podcast and all that stuff is under you
are not so smart
how minds change the new book uh how
minds change the surprising science of
belief opinion and persuasion i had to
actually look at the book just now to
remember what what the full title was uh
it's an actual real thing that i can
hold um
the
that you can find at davemcrainy.com or
just anywhere that books are at uh i'm
not going to tell you where to get it
but if you pre-order it i got all sorts
of pre-order bonuses for you including a
workshop and a video of a bunch of
persuasion experts talking to each other
so pre-ordering would be ideal since
that's how the the algorithms determine
my destiny but however you get it the
book is called how minds change david i
appreciate you thank you
thank you so much ma'am what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you